[Musique]
alors je sais pas quoi mais depuis rien
mais ça bon ça non ah non au regard
hagard égard garde à vue d'acheter hier
c'est du jaune
oui c'est des jo et lolo tu ne porte
jamais de jaune
oui je ne prendrais toi même nom mais
j'aimais bien le coup j'avais pas ça n'a
plus ce we will aller trop classe en bg
archi ce soir non c'est ma préférée et
j'ai eu pour pas cher voilà voilà tu
l'as vue pour pas cher voilà c'est ça le
problème assez d'efforts mais au premier
lavage ça bouge de partout ça non au
sort sont mariés un basculement ça
ressemble à rien et ses chaussures
journée de quatre couleurs au choix
quatre couleurs oui mais louloute déjà
prêté combien de fois au final c'est
porter un certain nombre de fois à la
barre résultat moi je sais pas quoi
mettre la natation il est bien là
celle-là bah oui on voit cela j'avais
tout le temps mais coup tout le monde la
connaît celle là mais justement qu'elle
est bien et va bien c'est vrai qu'il me
voit plutôt bien tu sais quoi on reste
telle qu'elle est enceinte corse qui a
mieux mais ouais m étais très bien comme
ça nous tout aussi
ça nous fait sourire
ça nous rappelle forcément quelque chose
je crois qu'on est nombreux à vivre ce
genre de situation et en même temps si
on creuse et ben ça peut aussi
questionné si on en vient à notre
dressing individuelle est ce que vous
savez que deux vêtements sur trois en
moyenne ne sont jamais portés et reste
dans nos placards
est ce que vous savez également que
chacun d'entre nous rejettent chaque
année en moyenne 11 kg de vêtements le
textile vous l'avez probablement déjà
entendu est considéré comme la deuxième
industrie la plus polluantes au monde
pour se donner une idée c'est 100
milliards de vêtements produits chaque
année quatre fois plus qu'en 1960 moitié
plus en 2030 si jamais on continue sur
ce rythme ce que vous voyez là c'est de
volume d'eau nécessaire à la production
d'un jean
dix mille litres c'est l'équivalent de
180 douche je vous laisse imaginer le
textile c'est aussi l'équivalent de 50
milliards de bouteilles de plastique
rejetées chaque année dans les océans du
fait des microfibres qui se détache de
nos vêtements à chacun des lavages et je
vais pas vous parler des pesticides
je vais pas vous parler des gaz à effet
de serre etc etc etc
alors forcément vu sous cet angle
ben laden du dressing c'est un petit peu
moins joyeux et pourtant c'est la
réalité
alors puisqu'on est tous ensemble ce
soir
moi j'aimerais bien qu'on se pose une
question une question essentielle une
question urgente
est ce qu'on a envie de continuer comme
ça
est ce qu'on peut continuer comme ça
bien sûr que non et la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'il est possible de faire
autrement et que ça dépend en grande
partie de nous je m'appelle josselin
j'ai 39 ans j'ai passé un petit peu plus
de 11 ans dans le prêt-à-porter
alors durant ses 11 années j'ai assisté
probablement contribué à cet emballement
du système mondialisation de la
production renouvellement incessant des
collections cette fameuse fast fashion
avec toutes ces dérives qu'elles soient
sociales environnementales et pourtant
j'avais l'impression de faire mon
travail faire en sorte que chaque
consommateur puisse avoir son produit en
tout lieu en toute heure et au bon prix
mais alors à qui la faute
les marques uniquement moi j'ai le
sentiment que si c'était le cas le
problème serait déjà résolu a priori la
marque vend ce que le consommateur
achète c'est la loi du marché de l'offre
et de la demande
partant de là il n'est plus possible
d'ignorer que le consommateur que nous
sommes fait clairement partie de
l'équation
nous sommes une clé indispensable pour
faire évoluer la situation
alors pour autant même si sa folie il
faut bien qu'on continue à s'habiller on
va pas se retrouver tous ensemble à dans
la rue demain avec juste une petite
feuille de vigne
1 on est d'accord on va cesser de la
marge on n'en est pas encore là mais
alors plus sérieusement comment on fait
eh bien ça commence par là juste une
carte bancaire vous allez bien en fait
ça c'est bien plus qu'une carte bancaire
c'est un véritable pouvoir que nous
avons dans les mains pourquoi parce qu'à
chaque fois que nous effectuerons un
achat nous faisons un acte de soutien
d'adhésion à la marque au produit mais
également à la manière dont il a été
conçu dès lors il devient indispensable
de se renseigner sur ce produit pour
faire un achat en conscience d'autant
plus que le textile aujourd'hui entame
finalement une phase de transition
un petit peu comme l'agroalimentaire il
ya un petit peu plus de 20 ans suite aux
crises sanitaires tels que la vache
folle la traçabilité apparaît elle
progresse et elle devient indispensable
nous savons comment bien remplir notre
frigo il devient indispensable de savoir
comment bien remplir notre dressing
pour ma part j'ai récemment choisi de
consacrer mon activité professionnelle à
cette fameuse traçabilité des vêtements
et finalement il existe plusieurs
manières de se renseigner sur cette
traçabilité le simple médine que vous
connaissez tous ne suffit pas à savoir
s'il ya un vêtement et éco responsable
alors commençons par regarder
l'étiquette de composition celle qui
indique les matières sur vos vêtements
et favorisons celles les moins
polluantes celles qui ne sont pas issus
de l'industrie du pétrole
favorisons les matières ayant le plus
faible impact environnemental
le coton biologique le caoutchouc
naturel les matières recyclées par
exemple favorisons également les
matières les moins gourmandes en eau le
chanvre la fibre de bois le lin dont la
france est le premier producteur mondial
alors quelques petits exemple certaines
marques
aujourd'hui plusieurs d'ailleurs propose
des jeans qui nécessite une consommation
de 20% en moins d'eau 40 douche
d'économiser pour un seul vêtement mais
c'est pas négligeable
d'autres marques proposent des vêtements
100 % à base de matières recyclées une
autre encore récemment a réussi à
produire à jean à base de laine de
mouton locale favorisons les produits
qui possède un label qui va vous
garantir l'absence de produits toxiques
pour le corps ou pour l'environnement
ayant un comportement éco responsable
en choisissant des vêtements qui dure et
qui ne vont pas se déformer au bout de
trois lavages pour finir trop rapidement
à la poubelle là encore des marques
récente en ont fait leur fer de lance à
propos des marques justement renseignons
nous sur leur histoire
certaines dévoile la liste des
fournisseurs voire même la manière dont
elle partage les bénéfices avec leurs
fabricants ça c'est un véritable pas en
avant pour améliorer les conditions de
production
d'autres vont consacrer une partie de
leur chiffre
faire les actions sociales ou
environnementales d'autres encore vont
planter des arbres construire des écoles
mener de vraies initiatives des vrais
démarche sincère pour améliorer les
conditions sociales sur les lieux de
production non la mode n'est pas
parfaite mais oui il existe des vraies
initiatives qui vont dans le bon sens
faite par des gens en conscience alors
une fois qu'on s'est dit ça il est
possible qu'on entende
oui ok la mode éco responsables d'accord
mais oui c'est cher
ok très bien mais elles sont là je vous
retourne la question est ce que vous
êtes sur certains de faire des économies
si vous achetez un produit qui ne
peuvent même pas faire une année dans
votre dressing
ouais d'accord mais faut un la mode éco
responsable c'est bien mais vous c'est
moche
ok chanteur
c'est très subjectif pourquoi fuck me
l'accorderez mais pourquoi pas je prends
c'est vrai qu'à ses débuts la mode
éthique était relativement
confidentielle avec un choix de style
peut être un petit peu particulier mais
le monde a changé
tous les jours des nouveaux produits
tous les jours des nouvelles lignes de
vêtements secret de quoi remplir chacun
de vos dressings
ah ouais mais moi la mode éco
responsables d'accord mais je sais pas
où trouver non alors lâché désole plus
aucune excuse comme on dit
le moteur de recherche est votre ami
chercher renseignez vous et vous verrez
que l'information existe juste apporter
clavier
la mode éco responsable est bel et bien
à notre portée et ce n'est que le début
alors vous l'avez bien compris il faudra
du temps beaucoup de temps parce qu'il
reste beaucoup de chemin à faire puisque
à priori produire c'est pollué mais le
changement est entamée et la vitesse de
ce changement dépend de vous chaque jour
de nouvelles marques secret pendant que
d'autres progressent chaque jour de
nouvelles initiatives des nouveaux
produits alors n'attendons pas que tout
soit parfait sinon dans dix ans on aura
toujours rien fait
soyons acteurs chercher renseignez vous
trouvez ce qui vous paraît le mieux ce
qui vous correspond le mieux
et moi eh bien je vous propose de
commencer dès à présent à partir
d'aujourd'hui puisque vous êtes là ce
soir vous ne pourrez plus dire que vous
ne saviez pas donc à chaque fois que
vous sortirez ce petit objet de votre
poche
promettez moi regarder les étiquettes
renseignez-vous sur la véritable
histoire de votre produit si nous le
faisons tous de manière systématique
nous montrerons aux marques et aux
fabricants de vêtements que l'éco
responsabilité est définitivement entré
dans nos critères de choix et que c'est
donc un critère fondamental et définitif
de production je compte sur vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]